We're friends,
so I'm gonna say this --
I'm gonna say this right now.
-Don't hurt him!
-Don't move.
[ Laughter ]
Stay right there.
Don't move at all.
-No, seriously,
because what if I --
-No. Seriously. Okay?
-No, but I don't like this
at all.
Can't we just talk
about the book?
-I have tremendous accuracy
with this deadly maneuver.
But if you move,
I will knock you out.
So...
-I don't like this at all, dude.
-Usually,
my opponent is incapacitated.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a second.
Tariq, do you want to try this?
-Don't move, damn it!
-He's a big fan.
-No!
-He's a big fan of yours.
-Listen, you asked about it.
Here it is.
Here's the
[Speaks Mandarin]
right up in your face.
So you get, like, a warm-up...
-Oh, my God.
-...and you say --
[Speaks Mandarin] in Mandarin
translates to "lightning fist."
So I'm a good guy
with a weather machine,
so I have
the power of lightning,
I say [Shouts in Mandarin]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whisper Challenge.
-So here's the thing.
It's a game. It's a game
you could play at home.
Here's how it works.
One person
puts on these headphones.
It's soundproof headphones
with loud music playing.
The other person
picks up a card,
reads the random phrase
on the card,
and the person wearing
the headphones has to try
and guess what they just said.
-Yeah, sure.
-Okay, good.
You put the headphones on first.
I'll make sure
these are working,
and I'll read you a phrase
and you'll guess
what I'm saying.
[ Dance music playing ]
Is it...?
Oh, hey.
Alright, it's working.
Alright, good.
Here we go. [ Clears throat ]
-It's gonna be really tough
for me.
-Alright, wait, hold on.
-Am I talking loud?!
-Yes, yes, yes.
-I am. Okay.
So I need to whisper
a little bit.
Do I whisper or do you whisper?
-No.
You're fine!
-Jimmy, I can't hear you.
-Alright.
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
I got this.
-Appletini.
-What?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
He was right. We're all winners.
-How did you get that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, no one's ever gotten it
on the first one.
How'd you get appletini?
-Listen to the music
you gave me, man.
It's just a loop that says,
"Appletini, appletini."
I'm kidding. It's not.
-Oh, my gosh.
That was fantast--
That was the best one ever.
I can't believe
you just did that.
Alright.
Whoa, whoa.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome to my world.
Alright. [ Clears throat ]
Okay.
-Slap m-- Slap my lap.
-No. No.
-Slappa lappa ding dong.
Shama lama ding dong?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-This is unbelievable.
We got it, man. We got this.
See? This is good.
We both win,
and it makes everyone feel good.
[ Laughs ] Gosh.
Alright. Ready for this one?
-Alright.
-Okay.
-This is going to be easy.
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
You didn't say anything.
You just went -- [Grumbles]
WrestleMania 33!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...two!
-Easiest one we've ever played.
Alright.
I'm ready for this, man.
Let's go. I'm like --
I'm excited. Appletini.
Got real heavy.
-This one is not real easy.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-[ Clears throat ]
-But I think we're good.
We got good chemistry.
-Yeah. No. Wait. Wait. Okay.
Start. [ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
-Do it -- Do it again. Slower.
-Dic your...
-No.
Ditch-uh...
Did you...
Dic...nose...
-No dic.
-No. Okay. No? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Di...
Dree-dree?
-Doo.
-Didgeridoo?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-We're all winners.
-Didgeridoo.
That's what I'm talking about.
John Cena, everybody!
-John and I
are about to face off
in a brand-new game
called "Fish Slap." Now --
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-It works like the game
"High or Low."
We'll take turns being dealer.
You deal one card,
then the other person guesses
whether the next one
will be higher or lower.
Aces are high.
If you guess wrong,
you get fish slapped. And, uh --
[ Laughter ]
The dealer gets to slap you with
a fish from their fish bucket.
[ Laughter ]
This is a real --
These are real --
-It really is.
-Yeah, they -- I can smell them.
-Yeah.
-They will be eaten by the crew
after the show.
[ Laughter ]
They won't be wasted.
Now, if you get
the exact same card,
we both slap each other
at the same time.
-In the event of a draw --
-Oh, my God. Double fish slap.
-Okay.
-The Internet is gonna break.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sighs ]
-Alright, first to fish slap
the other person three times
is the champion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughing ]
-Welp, yep. That's everything.
-Here we go.
-Alright.
-We've actually done everything.
Alright, so I go --
I'll deal first --
-Yes.
-To you.
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Do you trust these cards?
Do you want me to shuffle?
-No, I don't --
No, not at all.
We're gonna try it, though.
-Ooh.
-Oh, come on.
-Higher or lower,
that's pretty easy.
-Pretty easy?
It's right in the middle.
[ Laughter ]
Fallon, you son of a bitch.
-I didn't even hit you
with a fish yet!
What do you think?
Higher or lower? It's seven.
-Low.
-You're gonna go lower.
-Oh! You lucky -- You lucky --
Oh, my gosh.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, y-you won that one.
-Alright, Fallon.
-[ Inhales deeply ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, I don't know. Is it
going to be higher or lower?
I don't know, man."
-I hate your whole face.
-Now, does this mean I slap you
if I win?
-No, because I just won,
and no slaps happened.
I think it's if you lose.
If you lose.
-Okay.
-Alright.
I would slap you --
-Lower.
That's lower.
-You're going to go low?
-Definitely.
-Okay, great.
-That's actually really low.
Alright, wow, here we go.
Ready?
-High.
Good.
-I want to see some
fish slapping here.
Oh. Go low, low, right?
-Oh!
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, that's higher
than a queen!
Alright, be gentle, dude.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I just wanted
to get a feel for it.
-That slap was a real --
Can we have in it slow motion?
That slap was a bit backhanded
a little.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
There was a good little slap
to it.
And I smell like fish right now.
Here we go.
This is for you, right?
-High.
-You think?
[ Laughs ]
[ Audience oohs ]
-I will allow you the first --
-No, I've not done mine yet.
-Go for it.
-Are you sure?
-No, because then what if
I do it too hard, then you're
gonna want to retaliate?
[ Laughter ]
-Your fate lies
in your own hands.
Damn you, Fallon!
[ Laughter ]
-You can get this side, too.
-No, I wouldn't.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright, alright.
You're down to one fish.
I got two fish left.
This is --
If you're tuning in
or went for a bathroom break,
we're still playing "Fish Slap."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You would think
this would be easy. 10.
So I'm going to go low.
♪♪
-Okay.
-Alright, go ahead.
-High.
-Gosh.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Low!
-Aah!
-Aah! No!
You've got to be kidding me.
-In the name of salmon
and mackerel, the day is mine.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to get myself --
♪♪
-It was like hitting me --
it was like hitting me
with your -- with your arm!
Can we see that?
I feel like --
Slow motion.
This is for real.
Watch this.
Oh, my God!
See my jowls --
my jowls started shaking.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude,
you came up with this game.
-That's true, I did.
John Cena, the champ in the
first-ever game of "Fish Slap."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Truly a sportsman.
-John and I are about
to play a game of sticky balls,
which, of course,
refers to these balls
which stick to these
Velcro suits that we're wearing.
-What would they think it means?
-I don't know.
I'm just saying maybe like
we're making, like, a dessert.
Sticky balls.
Hey, we're gonna put
45 seconds on the clock.
-Dessert.
-And throw these sticky balls
at one another
until time runs out.
Once we're done,
John and I each will count
the sticky balls
stuck to the other guy.
The one with the most balls
stuck to his suit loses.
[ Drums playing ]
Questlove.
The first ball thrown
has to be one of the balls
on your center line here.
-Okay. Fair enough.
-Okay. Very good.
No crossing over
into the other guy's court.
-Just want you to know...
-No, I just...
That's a ballsy game, man.
Absolutely no removing of
the balls from your suit
once you've been hit.
-Okay. Fair enough.
-Perfect.
Now let's assume the position.
Alright, ready,
assume the position.
Hand on the wall.
Ready? Three, two, one.
Sticky ball!
-I'll kill you. You throw
something at me, I'll kill you.
-What are you talking about?
[ Cheering ]
[ Bell ringing ]
-That was actually pretty fun.
-Pretty good time.
-That's it right there.
Looks like it's close --
close game.
-Just two dudes playing
sticky balls, exhausted.
-John, John -- will you count
my balls, please?
-Oh, yeah.
Well, you at least got two.
-Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
-Four, I'm gonna save
that one for later.
I'm gonna need more...
[Speaks indistinctly]
Six...
8, 10...
This is a nice one, 12.
14.
-My spanx is coming off.
-15.
-15 balls.
-Hold on.
16 and one quarter.
17.
-17?
[ Cheering ]
One, two...
-Just do it, man.
-Three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12...
-Get the ones down low.
-13...
-[ Laughs ]
-14.
15.
-What's the damage?
How much do I owe you, man?
-It's a tie.
No, there isn't.
-Oh!
-18.
John Cena, everybody!
[ Cheering ]
My man, John Cena.
-John and I are about to face
off in a game of "Box of Lies."
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
They have to guess
whether you're lying
or telling the truth.
We're going to play
three rounds.
John, why don't you pick
the first box?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Far too far for me to reach.
I'm going to go for four.
Gonna go for four.
-I didn't hear one person
out there say four.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, doesn't seem that heavy,
but, then again,
you're John Cena.
-That's correct.
-Nothing is heavy to John Cena.
Okay.
♪♪
This is all part --
It's all part of the game
right now already.
He's deciding whether to tell
the truth or tell me a lie.
Okay.
-This object, Jimmy Fallon...
-Uh-huh.
-...is made of precious metal.
-Okay. Precious metal.
-And gemstones.
Precious metal and gemstones.
-It's beautiful to look at.
-Okay.
-And if you were
to see it up close,
you wouldn't be able
to look away.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's something bejeweled.
-It might be.
[ Light laughter ]
Actually, it certainly is,
because I just --
because I just told you it was.
-That's right.
Yeah, you did, yeah.
-And I am holding,
from box number four,
cosmetic lipstick.
-Lipstick.
-Yeah.
-So what you're saying
is it's a bejeweled lipstick.
-Yes.
-Why didn't you just say that
in the first place?
That's ridiculous.
I mean, this is the --
this is the dumbest thing
that anyone's ever done
in the history of the game
"Box of Lies."
If that's really
a lipstick container,
that took 20 minutes for you to
describe a lipstick container.
-This is your game, bro.
-Precious metal --
-I was just trying --
-Precious metals and gems?
-Yes, yes!
-It's a lipstick container?
-It is a lipstick container.
-You are telling the truth!
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-But it says -- it says,
"Open and twist."
-Yeah.
-Now, that --
-You shanghaied me!
-Now, that would have --
that would have been something
to talk about.
Here we go. Guys, what box?
What number?
[ Audience shouting ]
Three.
Give them what they want.
-Three. Go for it.
-[ Groaning ]
-So, it's not heavy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoop.
-I've seen you strain.
-[ Singing ]
-It's not -- It's not large.
It's not large.
You're trying to -- You're
trying to think up an untruth.
-It's not large.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's...
It's two little honeybees.
And they're -- they're, uh...
[ Laughter ]
They're playing --
What's that jump-rope game
that you jump --
-Double Dutch.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They're playing two double --
Two double bubbles.
-So you couldn't identify the
insects or the jump-rope game.
-The jump-rope game
double Dutch.
And, yeah.
And there's two fuzzy bumblebees
playing it.
And their friends that are
playing along with them are --
-You --
-Two --
-You are not good.
-They are two, um...
praying mantises.
-Oh, fantastic. Fantastic, yes.
Alright.
-Manti.
Praying manti.
-Okay, that -- You know what?
-The plural of "mantis."
-That swung me.
-There's no way
you're telling the truth.
You're lying.
♪♪
-Welcome to my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What number do you want
from John Cena?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I have a one.
I have a whole section.
Sorry, six guy.
I have a whole section
saying, "One."
Alright.
-"Six guy."
-One.
Forever be known as six guy.
Okay.
-Sorry, six guy.
-Alright.
-Whew.
Alright.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Light laughter ]
Okay.
♪♪
-It's art.
-Okay. It's art.
-I find it beautiful.
-Okay.
-I think it
combines industrialism
with the early stages
of television.
[ Light laughter ]
-Industrialism, okay.
-I hold in my hands
a red and black
double pinstripe model
of a 1970 Chevy Chevelle SS.
And in the driver's seat
is the Fonz.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the looks of it,
it looks like a four-speed car.
It does look like it has
a 12-bolt rear end.
It appears to be a big block.
It is a Super Sport model.
-I know you --
-The Fonz is wearing his classic
black leather jacket.
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
-He's a smaller figurine
in the passenger seat,
but it also looks like
he's wearing blue jeans,
if he has any pants on at all.
[ Light laughter ]
-So you're telling me -- you're
telling me that there's a --
there's a pantless Fonz
driving...
a 1970, like -- some type
of a souped-up muscle car.
-No, it's not --
Here's the thing.
It's not souped-up.
It is absolutely factory stock.
-Oh, keep talking, buddy.
Keep talking, 'cause guess what.
I know you, buddy.
I know you, Johnathan Cena.
Johnathan Cena, I know you.
And I know that you like cars.
So, I think
that you made this up.
This is a lie.
Is that right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
I love you, man.
I know you, dude.
I know you love cars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John Cena, everybody!
Oh, my goodness.